Istanbul city of Legends capital of
three former empires it sits at the
crossroads of Europe and Asia the only
city in the world that straddles two
continents
in the spring of 2004 a consortium of
international engineers began work on
the mumm-ra tunnel project this three
billion dollar rail system will tie in
the 47-mile commuter line with existing
networks the masterstroke of the project
is the 1.2 miles tunnel under the
Bosphorus just two miles from the
submerged tunnel a major hub station is
being built at Yanni kapa a busy suburb
inside the original Byzantine capital
engineers were empowered to scrape away
a swath of modern buildings among the
tons of sandy soil were the remains of
an extraordinary site a huge Roman built
Harbor dating to the 4th century AD dr.
lu fukuchi Bosch is one of the lead
archaeologists on the site he together
with a team of seven hundred and fifty
people have uncovered ancient city and
harbour walls and recovered thousands of
artifacts from the deep alluvial soil
while the discovery has delighted
historians it has completely derailed
the engineers
overnight work on the new station came
to a halt delaying the entire tunnel
rail link when it was discovered in 2005
the entire port was submerged in a sea
of soil there are several theories as to
why some put it down to nothing more
sinister than 700 years of river silt
but other experts believe the port's
demise was speeded up by a catastrophic
natural disaster fifteen of the ships
found that yani copper are thought to
have sunk at exactly the same time all
of them forced into the deep alluvial
sediment professor coach Abbas believes
the evidence points to one thing tsunami
a Japanese word meaning harbour wave is
usually the result of an earthquake
under the sea the engineers of the mama
rate tunnel project have been paying
close attention to these findings it's
unlikely that the submerged tunnel lying
deep underwater would be affected by a
tsunami but what about the stations
being built by the sea
entrances to the stations will be raised
to around 15 feet above sea level and
Jayant floodgates will automatically
close in emergencies the discoveries at
uni kapa have rapidly advanced our
understanding of ancient Constantinople
the key of this archaeological dig would
not have been possible if it wasn't for
the Marmara project and its engineers
and history has continued to inform the
Marmaray project on crucial decisions
[Music]
the Theodosian harbours discovery
informed engineers of the potential
devastation from a tsunami learning from
the past is part of living in Istanbul
and with a history stretching back
through millennia people here have
learned to be patient in Istanbul we
live on archaeology and we live in
history this tunnel will be built of
course it will be a little bit delayed
but we have waited to construct this
tunnel around 147 years we can wait a
couple of years more